I have to ask the brexit question about
your thoughts on what's going to happen
after that because it's such a hot topic
at the moment you said property you
think it's a great time to get in right
now while everyone's in certain what do
you think is going to happen in the
property market particularly what are
your predictions I mean I think brexit
or will get resolved for sure I think we
are thankfully and hopefully we're
coming towards the end I think the
election will be a big factor because if
the Conservatives get a majority then at
least Boris will be able to make a
decision and not be dependent on getting
a majority in the house of the
Parliament because the Conservatives
would have won through a majority which
he is clearly hopeful he's gonna do my
gut feeling is if I was a betting man I
would say he probably is gonna get a
majority if he gets the majority I think
we will leave Europe for sure
I think Boris has made it extremely
clear that's what he wants to do yeah I
think what the British people want is a
decision yeah I think the country is so
fed up with uncertainty and not knowing
it's the uncertainty that's dragging the
market down yeah the reason why the
market and real estate is down right now
because we don't know which way we're
going yeah I think as soon as you will
see certainty you will see the market
bounce so if you go back literally four
weeks ago when Boris came back from
Europe and he had a good meeting about
brexit the pound took off you know it
went from 122 to the dollar to 129 yeah
the stock market rallied right and all
of a sudden even in real estate people
saw a few transactions happening okay
now that was in the back of a meeting
yeah so when we leave Europe and we are
clear about where we're going
I absolutely believe there is a mall of
capital sitting right now waiting to be
deployed I think whether it's China
Europe Asia there are people who are
looking at the UK yeah right now I'm
but or not yeah so I think as soon as
you see clarity and certainty I think
you will see a bounce in the market
which is why I believe you've got a
short window of opportunity now because
if you wait and then your margins gone
you